[Musik]
in wenigen Tagen wird die Türkische
Republik 100 Jahre alt was ist geblieben
von den Idealen des Staatsgründers
Mustafa kimal
Atatürk kaum ein anderer Präsident seit
Attatürk hat die Republik so stark
geprägt und verändert wie Reb tayib
Erdogan seit 20 Jahren ist er an der
Macht 100 Jahre Türkei eine
Erfolgsgeschichte für die einen
Leidensgeschichte für
[Musik]
andere wie denken die die heute in der
Türkei leben über ihre Heimat sechs von
ihnen werden ihre Geschichten in diesem
Film
[Applaus]
erzählen
[Musik]
mein Name ist Fatma Bostan ich lebe
in ich bin Hausfrau mein Leben verbringe
ich im
[Musik]
Dorf die Berge in der Provinz Riese an
der Schwarzmeerküste im Nordosten der
Türkei es ist die Zeit der
[Musik]
tete ation schon leben die Bost in
diesem Tal meist blieb man unter sich
doch die Zeiten haben sich
[Musik]
geändert damals war alles ganz anders
wenn es da ein passables Mädchen gab im
Dorf und einen Burschen dann war klar
dass man die zusammenbringt heutzutage
wollen sich die jungen Leute selbst
ihren Partner aussuchen aber das ist
auch besser
so man und Faris Vater stammte aus dem
Dorf doch er starb früh mit 39 22 Jahre
ist das jetzt her beigesetzt haben Sie
ihn direkt neben dem
Haus damals gab es im Dorf keinen
städtischen Friedhof weil wir hier doch
sehr weit oben Leben ich wollte meinen
verstorbenen Mann auf meinem eigenen
Grund und Boden begraben hier im Dorf
macht das jeder so meine Schwester hat
ihren Friedhof auch direkt neben ihrem
Haus
Fari war damals noch ganz klein gerade
eineinhalb seine Brüder zogen ihn groß
die haben heute selbst Familien so
kümmert sich Fari um die Mutter dass sei
seine Pflicht
sagte wenn meine Mutter weil sie das
Familienoberhaupt ist das Problem nicht
lösen kann dann eben mein Bruder mein
Onkel oder meine Tante die Familie hat
für uns große
Bedeutung seine Onkel wohnen ein Stück
weiter unten sie führen den
Familienbetrieb weiter eine
Imkerei Bienenzucht und Teeanbau haben
Tradition bei den bostans ebenso wie ihr
muslimischer
[Musik]
Glaube mein Vater hat sich viel Mühe
gegeben hätte es meinen Vater nicht
gegeben hätten wir hier im Dorf keine
neue
Mosche er hat Geld gesammelt um die
Moschee zu
bauen wir haben auch geholfen aber das
meiste hat er selbst gemacht
[Musik]
freitags gehen sie runter in die Moschee
während der Woche betet Fatma Bostan zu
Hause fünfm am Tag unser Leben liegt in
Gottes Hand sagt sie und in der Hand des
Re ihres Präsidenten für den sie ihr
letztes Hemd geben
würden wofür wir
leben für unseren muzinruf für unsere
Religion für unsere Flagge und für unser
Land
das ist unsere rote Linie dafür stehen
wir bis zum letzten Tropfen
Blut während der Erntesaison bleibt
tagsüber nicht viel Zeit zum Essen es
gibt mlama Butter geschmolzener Käse
Milch Wasser Maismehl das geht schnell
erdogan hat uns Muslimen den Stolz
zurückgegeben sagtat seit Staatsgründung
waren Religion und Staat getrennt
Kopftuch in öffentlichen Gebäuden
verboten meine Kinder waren beim
Militärdienst und sind krank geworden
ich wollte meinen Sohn im Krankenhaus
besuchen gehen aber weil ich Kopftuch
trage haben sie mich nicht reingelassen
sie wollten unbedingt dass ich mein
Kopftuch abziehe aber ich bin standhaft
geblieben müssen wir heute immer noch
kämpfen
nein arbeitet Tags als Fahrer ur oder
den Tee zur
annahmestelleis Familie gehört zu jenen
52% die bei der letzten Wahl für Erdogan
stimmten der Präsident habe die Türkei
zu neuer Größe geführt sagen sie ja die
Inflation sei hoch es gebe Probleme doch
eine Nation zu führen meint Fatma Bostan
das sei schließlich nicht
einp
es wird immer Menschen geben die etwas
auszusetzen haben das können sie gerne
machen wir folgen unserem Race und
werden das auch
[Musik]
weiterun ich bin Türke Ertürk ich
binensier Admiral ich habe die marakadem
absolviert
ausgetreten ich mache seitdem Politik
und schreibe Kolumnen und
Bücher die Streitkräfte der Türkei
verstehen sich als Hüter der Republik so
auch Türker Ertürk Jahrgang
1957 Spross einer
Offiziersfamilie glühender Anhänger von
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk ehemaliger
Befehlshaber der Schwarzmeerflotte
exkommandur der türkischen
Marineakademie die Marine ist eine Art
Lifestyle auf der See zu sein auf der
See zu leben auf der See seinen Dienst
abzuleisten eine Kriegsflotte zu
befehligigen das ist ein
unbeschreibliches
Gefühl ich bin 2010 aus dem
Militärdienst ausgetreten warum weil
sich die Anhänger der gen
Terrororganisation in dasitär eeslichen
hatten und nicht aussortiert
wurden fetullah güen Chef einer streng
religiösen Organisation ehemaliger
Weggenosse Erdogans der ihn heute als
Terrorist bezeichnet denn gulen soll
hinter dem Putschversuch von 2016 stehen
Ertürk sagt er habe vor der geplanten
Revolte gewarnt doch man habe nicht auf
ihn
gehört
es hätte verhindert werden können aber
das haben sie nicht die Regierung hat
von den Plänen gewusst und hat den
putchversuch für ihre eigenen Zwecke
missbraucht erdogan hat den putch als
Gottes Geschenk bezeichnet denn die
Verhaftungen alle Operationen gegen das
Militär und gegen die Bürokratie haben
erst danach an Fahrt gewonnen es hat
einee in Gang gesetzt die zum Ziel hatte
den genetischen Code desitärs zu
es ist der Vers gewesen den unter seine
eene krolle zu
[Musik]
bringen aus Protest gegen die
Entmachtung der Militärs quittiert ertk
den Dienst er geht in die Politik tritt
in die CHP ein die Partei die
1923 von kimal Atatürk
selbstndet 1938 gestorben hat das
irgendeine Auswirkung auf mich
persönlich nein er ist gestorben aus und
vorbei ich folge keinem toten Mann ich
folge Atatürks Ideen ich folge seiner
Idee der Aufklärung das bedeutet für
mich die Abschaffung der Monarchie dass
die staatliche Souveränität in den
Händen von Menschen liegt und nicht in
den Händen Gottes und dass die Frau in
der neuen Ordnung ihren rechtmäßigen
Platz erhalten
hat
für mich haben erdoan und die die hinter
ihm stehen ein Problem mit dieser
revolutionären Aufklärung sie können
sich nicht damit
identifizieren das kann man aus Erdogans
Aussagen raushören diese Leute sehen
sich nach dem Osmanischen Reich zurück
und brüsten sich
damit Laizismus bedeutet die strikte
Trennung von Religion und Staat Religion
hat in den Belangen des Staates Derk
Rees und der Bildung nicht verloren
erdogan ist gegenüber dem Laizismus
voreingenommen er glaubt nicht an eine
religionsreform Erdogan rütele an den
Grundfesten der Republik er habe das
Militär entmachtet den Laizismus
abgeschafft die Macht müsse wieder vom
Volk ausgehen nicht von einem Mann der
Präsident plane seit langem eine
Verfassungsreform damit wolle er seine
eren sagt erürk doch erdan werde damit
keinen Erfolg
[Musik]
haben ja man hat das türkische Militär
zum Schweigen gebracht und
eingeschüchtert aber der genetische Code
unseres Militärs wird immer derselbe
bleiben Loyalität zur Republik zu den
Ideen der Aufklärung zu
Atatürk
[Musik]
ich bin Sil eine Armenierin aus diakir
ich habe das Buch Amidas Tisch
geschrieben über die Küche von diabakir
ich bin
kulturforscherin Amida so nennen die
Armenier ihre Stadt diabakir im Osten
der Türkei Sil hier uns wiederid Tisch
deckenamals nocheleenier
le ich werde eine Art Festessen Kochen
pilureis ichch Köfte und dazu noch
Dolma früher haben wir das hier selbst
auf unseren Dächern getrocknet jetzt
kaufen wir es ein für das Gericht das
wir kochen wollen brauchen wir ganz
besonders gute getrocknete
Tomaten nach dem Einkaufen zeigt sie uns
die Orte ihrer Kindheit oder das was
davon übrig geblieben ist wie die Kirche
St Georg hier wird sie
1965 getauft nicht weit entfernt die ST
josefkirche die Familie lebt direkt
nebenan die Kinder gehen auf eine
städtische türkische
Schule meine Schwestern wurden in der
Schule ständig gemobbt man hat sie
hatcho hacho gerufen
Ungläubige und sie wurden verprügelt so
war das während meiner Kindheit wenn wir
auf die Straße g haben NAB komische
Gesten Gemach sie sagten dass wir darauf
spucken sollen und zeigten auf das
Kreuz deshalb war meine Mutter sehr
vorsichtig sie ließ uns nicht mehr so
oft raus auf die Straße
gehen die Geschichte der Armenier in der
Region ist eine Geschichte von
Vertreibung Tod und Zerstörung dem
völkermordff den dieür
he
f nach Gründung der türkischen Republik
lebt in diabir nur noch eine kleine
Gemeinde jede Aktion gegen Christen
selbst im weit entfernten Zypern war
auch eine Aktion gegen uns erinnert sich
[Musik]
silver die zypernoperation von
1974 war wie der letzte Nagel im sag der
Christen von
diabakir es gab eine Abwanderung nach
der anderen denn Angst ist genauso
ansteckend wie Mut alle hatten
Angst ihre Familie zieht fort nach
Istanbul dort lebt silver bis heute wie
die meisten Armenier die noch im Land
sind in der ganzen Türkei sind es
vielleicht noch 6 von
[Musik]
einmli Geschichte hat sie ein Buch
geschrieben ein Kochbuch weil ich eine
gute Köchin bin sagt silver weil die
Rezepte von meinem Leben erzählen und
weil es um das gemeinsame geht nicht um
das
[Musik]
Trennende alle die in diesem Land leben
ernähren sich von dem was uns dieses
Land
bietet daher sind der Boden und derch
sehr
verbindend so dachte ich es wäre richtig
diese Geschichten mit Hilfe von Rezepten
zu
[Musik]
schreiben dieses Gericht heißt perdeli
pilau wir Armenia bereiten die
reisfüllung mit Mandeln und Rosinen zu
dann umwickeln wir den Reis mit einem
dünnen darmnetz wir nennen es die
lammhaut und das Backen wir dann im Ofen
es ist ein festm und eines der Gerichte
fetagen auf den Tisch
gehört Reis Humus Joghurt Suppe gefüllte
Auberginen und Paprika ein armenisches
Festmal in ihrer Heimatstadt
diabakir sie sind wieder zu Hause und
fühlen sich doch wie die ungeliebten
Kinder der
[Musik]
Republik ich wünte
wir Vater ist der keine Unterschiede
zwischen den Kindern macht wir sind
jetzt nur noch sehr wenige wir sind wie
ein Lebewesen das vom Aussterben bedroht
ist und beschützt werden muss wenn wir
ganz verschwinden wird die Türkei
farblos und eintönig
[Applaus]
[Musik]
werden ich
heinboren
groß geworden 1973 wurde ich ins
Parlament gewählt mache seit 50 Jahren
aktiv
[Musik]
Politik Kri kanjo das Familiengut des
kanjo Clans kurdische Aristokratie
kurdischer Freiheitskampf Ahmed TK ist
Clanchef und Respektsperson für die
einen Terrorist und Hassfigur für viele
andere es gibt Leute den nicht im selben
Film auauchen
wollen meine Familie und der
Verwandtenkreis sind sehr groß auch die
Verbundenheit zwischen uns ist groß
nicht wie in
Europa auch wenn jemand nicht aus der
gleichen Familie stammt müssen wir
trotzdem das Recht dieses anderen
Schützen wenn er unserem Clan
angehört stet Haus eines Verstorbenen
Schwagers den
es ist ein Patriarchat Männer und Frauen
sitzen
getrennt im Frauenzimmer trifft Türk
seine ältere Schwester Cousinen Nichten
alles Familie sagt
er die beileitsbekundung ist bei uns
Kurden sehr wichtig früher konnte das
Fest bis zu 10 15 Tage dauern wir haben
es auf drei Tage verkürzt um die
Familien nicht noch mehr zu
strapazieren es ist eine strenge
geschlossene Gesellschaft die eigenen
Gesetzen gehorcht und die ihre Rechte
einfordert mit rund 19%
Bevölkerungsanteil sind die Kurden die
größte ethnische Minderheit der Türkei
Staatsgründer Attatürk habe die Kurden
damals als gleichwertige Mitglieder der
Volksgemeinschaft bezeichnet sagt
Türk doch nach Ausrufung der Republik
wurden Existenz und Rechte der Kurden
unter der Doktrin des nationalst nach
und nach
zurückgenommen in einer Region in der
viele unterschiedliche Kulturen und
Identitäten Leben ist man mit einer
nationalistischen Logik
vorgegangen was heißt das ein
Nationalstaat betreibt mit Hilfe dieser
Politik die Auflösung der sogenannten
anderen er predigt ein Volk ein Staat
das ist die Denkweise von
Nationalstaaten für seine Gegner ist
Türk ein Sympathisant der terrormiliz
PKK ein Terrorist er sitzt jahrelang im
Gefängnis wird gefoltert doch er macht
weiter
[Musik]
Politik das kurdische Neujahrsfest Ende
Mai in diabakir veranstalter ist die
prokurdische Partei
HDP für sie ist nevros das freiheitsfest
die Staatsmacht aber will jede
freiheitsbestrebung der
[Musik]
madstra des nichts als sinnlose
schik sie wollen uns und die Massen
trennen dabei würden keine Probleme
entstehen wenn sie nicht eingreifen
würden was soll schon passieren unsere
Leute verstehen uns sie kommen umros zu
Feier wenn Sie diese Sicherheitszonen
einrichten und Mauern zwischen uns und
dem Volk errichten zeigen die Menschen
eine
Reaktion und das ist kein schönes
[Musik]
Bild schauen Sie tausende kurdische
Politiker sitzen heute in Haft nur weil
sie ihre Meinung und Gedanken freie
äußern weil sie ihre Rechte ihre
Identität ihre Kultur einforder
man sagt immer die wollen die Türkei
teilen aber das wollen wir gar nicht
ganz im Gegenteil wir haben kein Problem
mit dem türkischen Volk wir wollen mit
dem türkischen Volk in Freiheit und
Gleichheit
Zusammenleben das ist unser
[Musik]
verständlich
ich J alt und Studentin ich arbeite in
einer Tierarztpraxis als
[Musik]
veterinärmedizinerin Istanbul der
schwarzmeerstand von kilios alkim Schir
kennt nur einen Präsidenten Reb tayb
Erdogan und seine islamisch konservative
Regierung ich habe keine großen Träume
wie z.B ein tolles Auto ein großes Haus
oder so ich will nur dass ich glücklich
bin glücklich mit meiner Arbeit und den
Menschen die mich
umgeben doch zur Zeit drehe sich in der
Türkei alles um die schlechte Wirtschaft
und um
Politik viele meiner Freunde sind im
Ausland wo es völlig egal ist wer als
Regierungschef gewählt worden ist bei
uns ist das eine Frage von Leben oder
Tod es ist Samstag Nachmittag alkem und
ihre Freundin chidem wollen am Abend auf
ein technokonzert chidem hat ihr
Wirtschaftsstudium abgeschlossen und
sucht nach einem
Job die beiden wollen sich für den Abend
in Stimmung bringen doch das Budget ist
knapp im Laden um die Ecke kostet eine
kleine Flasche Gin 12 € so viel kostet
auf dem Konzert ein einziges Glas
meint
wir trinken bevor wir auf das Konzert
gehen dort gibt's dann vielleicht nur
einen einzigen Drink so müssen wir das
halt
machen meine Mutter hat mir Sachen aus
ihrer Jugend erzählt die ich einfach
nicht fassen kann dass sie bis nachts
auf dem taxiplatz unterwegs waren sich
dort betrunken und gefeiert haben nachts
um 3 oder 4 Uhr sein sie als Mädels
allein nach Hause gegangen wenn ich das
heute mache frage ich mich wie komme ich
nachts alle zurück nach Hause darf ich
mich so anziehen oder lieber nicht das
hat alles mit dem konservativen Regime
zu
tun zu jungen Leuten wie Ihnen habe die
Regierung den Kontakt verloren sagen sie
die Stimmung im Land sei konservativer
[Musik]
geworden früher war das Nachtleben noch
aktiver in Istanbul es gab mehr Events
mit der Pandemie kam die Schließung aber
dass sich das bis heute bis September
2023 gehalten hat da ist meiner Ansicht
nach die Regierung
scholdld eigentlich sollten Sie doch am
Nachtleben viel
verdienen Istanbul zieht doch Unmengen
von Touristen an aber das sind nicht die
Touristen die sie anziehen wollen ja
genau das ist wahrscheinlich nicht deren
Klientel deswegen nehmen Sie Abstand von
Nachtclubs und setzen eher auf andere
Sachen alles für die
Araber viel wichtiger als das aber ist
ihnen die Sorge um die
Zukunft ich wollte mit meinem Freund
zusammenziehen wir haben uns das mal
durchgerechnet wir müssten uns
finanziell von unseren Familien
unterstützen lassen und das wollen wir
nicht wir haben studiert haben einen
Abschluss sind erwachsen wir wollen auf
eigenen Beinen stehen ich bin 23 Jahre
alt
alkim und schidem denken so wie viele
aus der jungen türkischen Generation
ihnen ist es in ihrer Heimat Türkei zu
eng
[Musik]
geworden viele meiner Freunde sind zum
Studium ins Ausland gegangen ich hatte
auch die Möglichkeit das zu tun aber ich
wollte damals nicht von meiner Familie
und den anderen Freunden
weg jren ja so in den letzten Z Jahren
ist es wirtschaftlich und sozial immer
schwieriger
geworden ich habe nur ein Leben und das
möchte ich genießen können ich will
meinen Kopf frei haben deswegen möchte
ich im Ausland
promovieren ob ich danach auch im
Ausland bleibe oder in die Türkei
zurückkomme dahinter steht immer noch
ein
[Musik]
Fragezeichen
ich heiße jorgo sarbosan mein Spitzname
lautet barborgo ich habe hier eine
Taverne göada ist die größte Insel der
Türkei die Griechen nennen sie
imros jorgo sarbosan wurde auf imros
geboren
199 vor 84 Jahren seine ganze Jugend hat
er hier
verbracht jeden Samstag kamen hier 45
bis 50 junge Menschen Jungen wie Mädchen
zusammen bis in die frühen Morgenstunden
haben wir getanzt 1964 wurde dieser
Platz enteignet und eine Polizeiwache
wurde gebaut damit war das Tanzlokal
nicht mehr da so war das s man
machen Besuch am Grab des Vaters nach
Gründung der Republik wurden zwei von
Griechen besiedelte
esinseln der Türkei zugesprochen im Zuge
des sogenannten
bevölkerungsaustausches verließen die
meisten Griechen die Türkei einige
tausend blieben auf göada doch in den
60er Jahren kam es zu Enteignungen
Schulen wurden geschlossen jorgo verließ
die Insel ging nach Istanbul studierte
heiratete leitete eine eigene
Firma aber in Gedanken war ich immer
hier ich habe 38 Jahre in Istanbul
gelebt aber jeder Nacht war ich in
meinen Träumen
hier jo kehrte
1996 zurück baute das Elternhaus wieder
auf eröffnete eine Taverne er wollte das
Leben der alt Griechen nach
[Musik]
zurückbringen
ist dort mit Vater
befreundet natürlich erinnere ich mich
an ihn als
Kind ist immer noch ein kleines
Kind er hat uns zwar immer geärgert
trotzdem hatte er uns sehr
gern stelio Berber ist Musiklehrer und
Direktor der griechischen Schule auf vor
Jahren wurde die Schule wieder eröffnet
seitem die Kinder griechischer Sprache
unterrichtet
[Musik]
werden die Schulen waren 49 Jahre
geschlossen in dieser Zeit wurden
mehrere altgriechische Generationen
nicht hier geboren sie wuchsen an
anderen Orten auf und es fand ein Bruch
mit der
inselstad dies wieder rückgängig machen
zu wollen und an den Ursprung
zurückzukehren war nicht
einfach gemeinsamer Protest von Griechen
und ihren türkischen Nachbarn gegen das
Verbot einer Fotoausstellung über die
Enteignung der altgriechen auf der Insel
die türkischen Behörden verweigern die
Genehmigung hier stellt sich nicht die
Frage ob Grieche Türke oder Kurde hier
geht es um die
Meinungsfreiheit durch Konfrontation s
eine den dagegenhren wir uns alle
gemeinsam und ich denke das ist eine
sehr wertvolle
Aktion die historische Feindschaft
zwischen Griechen und Türken ist hier
sehr weit weg ich bringe sie zusammen
sagt jo sarbosan damit Sie sehen wie
ähnlich wir uns doch eigentlich
sind früher war ich bei allen Festen
dabei heute sind es die jungen Menschen
die das Organisieren
wo ich helfen kann versuche ich das zu
tun ich danke
euch ich wünsche allen ein glückliches
[Musik]
Leben sechs Biografien sechs Blicke auf
ein Land mit einer langen wechselvollen
Geschichte dass es sich und seinen
Menschen nie leicht gemacht
hat
[Musik]